l'otan a renforcé substantiellement sa
présence militaire sur le front est dans
les pays alliés à la frontière de ses
états membres au total l'organisation
compte quarante mille soldats placés
directement sous sa direction sur le
front oriental quatre bataillons
multinationaux représentant environ 5000
soldats sont déjà déployés en estonie en
lettonie en lituanie et en pologne les
35 mille autres soldats multinationaux
sont répartis dans d'autres pays de
l'otan ils sont opérationnels et prêts à
être mobilisé quatre nouveaux bataillons
multinationaux devrait prochainement
être déployé en slovaquie en hongrie en
roumanie et en bulgarie
ces renforts porteront donc à huit le
nombre de bataillons multinationaux
déployés sur le front oriental de l'otan
s'ajoutent des soldats déployés
individuellement par les états membres
de tous les états le déploiement
américain et de loin le plus important
avec un total de cent mille hommes
présents en europe un contingent qui a
vocation à être renforcée